احنا غزه دمار غزه ما فيش فيها حياه
الشهداء مرميه على الارض الاصابات على
الارض الدور مهدمه عينينا لما وصلنا لهنا
علينا معاناه كبيره لما وصلنا لهنا انا
بقيت في مستشفى الرنتيسي اقتحموها اليهود
وطلعنا من مستشفى الرنتيسي طلعنا على
الجلاه من الجلاه قعدنا نتنقل من منطقه
لمنطقه فش منطقه في غزه امنه حتى الاسعاف
كانت تمرق نوقفها نطلق سكر انسولين ما فيش
من التسعه صبحنا مرمين بالشوارع ماي ما
بعلم فيه لربنا يعني حتى لما بقولوا نا
روحوا على الجنوب الجنوب شفنا الم يعني لس
لوت احسن الحطان علينا رحنا على المدرسه
الفخوره قصفنا في المدرسه وين بدنا نروح
رحنا على الاندونيسي قصفوا في الاندونيسي
يعني احنا فيش ملجا ناش مكان امن الا في
مصر اليوم فيش مكان
امن